joining us now to set the record
straight is presidential historian
author of the fabulous book so many of
them Reagan rising and Citizen Newt
Craig Shirley along with Elizabeth
Warren's conservative challengers now an
independent self-described real Indian
on his an MIT scientist Shiva I adore a
focus both both of you it's great to
have you on Craig gotta start with you
Andrew Jackson okay the it is one of the
paintings up in the Oval Office that's
true I've been in the Oval Office one of
my favorite paintings and beautiful
painting set the record straight here
Reagan also hung enter Jackson in the
Oval Office another racist yeah exactly
every president of the 19th century
prosecuted the war against the American
Indians Abraham Lincoln who one of the
calls and embassies cited as being an
example for Trump also prosecuted there
were massacres in Minnesota there are
massacres in Colorado there was a forced
relocation there were hangings of
Indians so Abraham Lincoln also and by
and even into the 20th century you know
Phil Sheridan who'd been General of the
Union Army coined the phrase went out to
go after Indians in the West and he
coined the phrase the only good Indian
is a dead Indian
Teddy Roosevelt said he agreed with that
statement but he might cut out 1 out of
10 Indians and and give them some
consideration that your point is
criticism they do it to robert e lee
it's a it's a whitewashing this is
what's known as presentism this is the
fallacy resent ism yes the fallacy of
imposing current Morrie's and values on
the acts and people of the past it's
arrogant and it's stupid and it's
ignorant and it it proves no point other
than the arrogance of the present people
making the trip you see this deal
Hughley entertainer come on and they
said tons of indians are killed now
we're measuring them and wait i'm into
the videos guilt it's it's but this is
the level of ignorance yes on some of
these other cable outlets that hold
themselves out as high and mighty by the
way David McCullough said we are now in
our third generation of historically
ignorant Americans and this gentleman
proves it she've I've got to go to you
you you actually sent Elizabeth Warren
something for her birthday now you're
running against her as an independent
and you call yourself what Shiva the
real Indian and the race
because you are a real yai we've been
saying Lawrence and only a real Indian
can defeat the fake Indian and that
point that we're making it hits at a
very very deep level and it makes
everyone chuckle you know and the reason
it makes people chuckle oh because we're
bringing out a very very apparent truth
that the liberal white elites the white
liberals don't want to discuss and
that's the following if you look at what
Elizabeth Warren has actually done she
shoplifted someone's identity and then
when it's exposed as President Trump did
accurately they throw tantrums and call
people racist in fact I was called a
racist for exposing her and sending her
the DNA test kit you're like a triple
PhD violated biological sciences of by a
four degrees from MIT yeah that my PhD
in biological engineering okay it's are
you really smart um so you you sent her
a DNA test kit which she refused she
didn't acknowledge didn't send a
thank-you note I understand you do that
may be the instruction I was very
disappointed oh the resection
they were the Sioux language yeah right
just get the code talkers in it but
Shiva I want to play for you now
Elizabeth Warren takes issue with your
claims against her Indian heritage
Native American heritage let's just
review what she said
to verify her Indian heritage let's
watch I still have a picture on my
mantle at home and it's a picture of my
mother had before that a picture of my
grandfather and my Aunt Bea has walked
by that picture at least a thousand
times remarked that he that her father
my papaw had high cheekbones like all of
the Indians do that makes me laugh every
time I hear but it's a serious point she
faked a minority status to list herself
at the Harvard Law directory to get
special privileges and special treatment
I don't care what she says that's what
it's a cultural stereotyping everyone
and enhance high cheekbones in that form
racism a Cherokee term papaw I didn't
know I'm not sure about that I got a big
issue here I think the big issue here is
you have someone who says that they
fight for the working people fight for
the poor fight for people of color and
she has exploited that for her own
benefit and this is not about when when
they claim the President Trump is making
this a racial slur in fact she is the
one who's a racist because a she took
advantage of someone's race she
shoplifted someone's identity and when
it's exposed they start screaming and
throwing tantrums like children and
that's a fundamental issue here and
what's fascinating is you know
Massachusetts is where the revolution
took place the irony is Massachusetts
has now become the Haven of the sewer
that feeds a swamp in Washington DC and
what I see happening is in our defeating
Elizabeth Warren what we hope to do is
to send a wave out that independence
everyday people people actually work for
a living innovators entrepreneurs
business people like President rothmeyer
deserve to participate in governance and
that's what you love your bravado I love
the fact that you centered the DNA just
kid day I want Craig to msf the racial
obsession is not lies joe scarborough's
today said that he only does this for
you only he only defends white
anglo-saxon Protestants or something
like that he said well he's obsessed
with people who are not white like
criticizing them he went
they are the elites are obsessed but are
obsessed yes it's a way of diverting
attention this is right out of the book
the Screwtape Letters is divert
attention that things are not important
so you don't talk about the things that
are important like our failing public
schools which can be laid at the feet of
liberalism or failing government or all
the other things that look Craig your
book citizen knew it was fabulous learn
a lot from the 1994 period she have us
great to see you we'll have both of you
back thank you